ce musée pourrait c'est vrai ce musée on
nous dit un musée de réflexion le musée
d'idées intéressantes c'est très moderne
la poste passe profondeur nous idée
alors ayons des idées profitons-en pour
raconter l'histoire du canada pour se re
visiter ce chemin parcouru de ce pays
qui est très jeune finalement le musette
à la fourche
le musée est à la forge d'art et
assiniboine et de la rivière rouge
le lieu précis où on a écrasé les droits
des métis et des franco manitobain des
métis et des cris
c'est difficile laquelle les canadiens
soit en français ou en anglais ont
beaucoup de difficulté à regarder le
passé et a regardé ses relations avec
les autochtones par exemple il le canada
ne reconnaît pas du tout sauf ciel
sophie ciel policiers ne reconnaît aucun
génocide à l'intérieur de ses frontières
c'est factuellement faux on peut jouer
sur les mots on peut dire que ça s'est
produit à terre neuve mais quelle époque
c'était pas le canada mettez en avait
deux provinces canadiennes
et là il ya eu un génocide réel
documenté connu mais que les canadiens
ne connaissent pas fait un sondage aux
quinze ans avec l'éducation puisque
parmi les gens éduqués donner le nom de
shana ddte par des libéraux truc parler
de l'histoire des baies au dessus des
britanniques et des français qui les ont
exterminé personne ne cessant personne
est au courant de ça et là sont vos plus
loin ensemble dans l'histoire
douloureuse
moi si je suis canadien chips il ya un
musée je suis sûr comité on va regarder
ils veulent commémorer
bien sûr on a collé un commémorer
l'holocauste comme les arméniens puis ça
on a nos nos grandes tragédies
humanitaires universels mais pour moi
l'anthropologue l'historien et le nord
américain passionné de diversité
culturelle amérindienne un des plus
grandes tragédies de l'humanité c'est
l'amérique se passe rien
très peu de gens savent qu'elles
l'amérique du nord l'amérique centrale
et l'amérique du sud et bien y avait une
population équivalente à la population
européenne au nom du contact
donc c'est pas une europe surpeuplé qui
rencontrent des heures américain avec
3,4 sauvage qui se promènent avec des
clubs il y avait les aztèques y avait
les uns car il y avait des populations
il y avait des démographies très
importante jusqu'au
mississippi jusqu'à aujourd'hui dans
l'ohio il y avait ici des nations
partout il ya aucun lieux des heurts et
ces gens vont disparaître à 80 pour ça
il n'y a rien qui va changer
qui aime ces gens n'auront pas repris le
contrôle politique de leur destin
collectif
c'est assez simple mais c'est comme ça
tant qu'ils reportent parlement mais des
décisions politiques américaines trésor
public analyse et au canada puis donc un
troisième pouvoir littéralement à
l'échelle fédérale
moi j'avais imaginé j'ai vu des gens
propose en outre une chambre des
représentants par ottawa dépôt les
amérindiens mais tant que remplaçant
avec des reconnaissances territoriale
donc non juste des nouvelles
juridictions la créativité et
l'inventivité et de dire donc tu veux
être tu veux être assiniboine active et
assiniboine la tribu ait agi bouée à la
sauvette agi bruit soit audible parce
que dans ce pays tout en 3d toshiba ou
tard des écoles j bolt va chanter à nos
jours heureux et puis les gens vont te
regarder c'est la prochaine étape est là